[Musique]
bonsoir le journal de tv soixante dix
huit pour un condensé d'actualité locale
bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez dans
cette édition du mercredi 9 décembre
voici les titres
c'est un sujet diffusé dans complément
d'enquêté sur france 2 qui a mis le feu
aux poudres des cas de cancer rare du
cerveau ont été révélés parmi les
salariés d'atos et les habitants du
bassin de vie autour du site implanté
aux clayes-sous-bois est dans le viseur
trois antennes relais qui entoure les
locaux du géant de la transformation
digitale une enquête est en cours
le cap est fixé par emmanuel macron
repassé sous la barre des 5000 nouveaux
cas de kovy 19 par jour pour lever le
confinement du 15 décembre mais cet
objectif paraît inatteignable et le
gouvernement réfléchit à une nouvelle
stratégie
le premier ministre doit s'exprimer
demain quels sont les derniers chiffres
de l'épidémie dans les yvelines les
acteurs du monde culturel sont ils
inquiets d'un possible revirement
éléments de réponse interview dans cette
édition avec gérard larcher président du
sénat l'ancien maire de rambouillet
s'exprime à notre micro sur les
présidentielles à venir et sur son
soutien à une autre yvelinoise valérie
pécresse dans la campagne des élections
régionales
enfin il s'en vend chaque année environ
six millions en france le sapin est un
incontournable des fêtes et cette année
ne dérogera pas à la règle malgré la
crise sanitaire
reportage à saint-cyr-l'ecole aux
essarts-le-roi et puisqu'on parle des
fêtes à la fin de ce journal focus
également sur le noël décalé qui se
tiendra cette année à la commanderie en
version online
à la france rend hommage ce mercredi une
semaine après la disparition de valéry
giscard d'estaing il s'est éteint des
suites ducobu 19 à l'âge de 94 ans
mercredi 2 décembre président de la
république de 1974 à 1981 un seul
septennat à l'origine de réformes
progressistes abaissement de la majorité
à 18 ans dépénalisation de l'avortement
et libéralisation de l'information ou
encore divorce par consentement mutuel
pour commémorer sa mémoire emmanuel
macron a décrété donc aujourd'hui une
journée de deuil national une
reconnaissance sobre conforme à ce que
souhaitait valéry giscard d'estaing qui
ne voulaient pas d'hommage national lé
drapeau de l'ensemble des bâtiments
publics de france ont été mises en berne
c'est le cas sur ces images à voisins le
bretonneux et à est cuit en cours
une minute de silence également observée
à la mi-journée dans plusieurs
institutions notamment ici à montigny le
bretonneux où une quarantaine de
personnes élus agents de la commune et
habitant à s'est réunie devant l'hôtel
de ville pour saluer une dernière fois
le 20e président de l'histoire de la
république française
enterrée pour rappel samedi dernier chez
lui dans le loir et cher
elle les propos recueillis par bixente
maria santis tebbane c'était important
parce que c'était un grand chef d'état
et un grand réformateur qui a porté des
choix de course la société française
extrêmement important qu'ils ont fait
basculer dans l'ère moderne et donc il
s'appuyait aussi sur des valeurs par
rapport à la liberté et les droits et
l'égalité hommes femmes est aussi sur
l'europe qui sont qui nous sont très
chers nouveau particulièrement à
montigny donc il nous semblait vraiment
importante pouvoir lui rendre hommage
aujourd'hui et je vous le disais dans
les titres des éléments révélés par nos
confrères de france 2 dans complément
d'enquêté suscite la polémique en ce
moment plusieurs cas de cancer rare du
cerveau chez plusieurs salariés d'atos
aux clayes-sous-bois est pas remis à des
habitants des environs inquiète trois
antennes relais autour des bâtiments du
groupe sont notamment dans le viseur les
précisions dasri bergère des anciens
salariés et d'autres toujours en poste
chez atos aux clayes-sous-bois ont
développé des cancers du cerveau
révélée par complément d'enquêté
l'affairé fait grand bruit cette
multinationale spécialiste des services
informatiques est en plus des nombreux
serveurs et salles informatiques
entouré de trois ans
relais entre 2015 et 2019 sept cas de
cancer rare du cerveau ont été observés
chez les salariés y at il un lien avec
les ondes électromagnétiques présentes
sur le site
personne ne peut le prouver aujourd'hui
des investigations sont toujours en
cours
une enquête a été diligentée avec la
composition d'un groupe d' alerte en
santé du travail ce gast avait pour
objectif de mettre en place différentes
études au cours du premier trimestre
2009 un compte tenu de la suspension des
investigations dugast en raison de la
déclaration de la crise sanitaire liée à
l'épidémie de courant la virus valable
le maire dé le déconfinement a saisi
officiellement par courrier en date du
13 et du 20 mai 2020 le préfet des
yvelines et les autorités sanitaires
compétentes un changement de maire a élu
en juin 2020 mais la position reste la
même
les investigations du gaston repris et
un nouveau rendez vous est organisé avec
la mairie dans le mois mais cette
commune n'est pas la seule concernée
au total dans les villes des
clayes-sous-bois de villepreux et de
plaisir dix autres cas de cancers
similaires ont été recensés moi en tant
que maire j'ai deux responsabilités la
première elle est allée au niveau de la
santé avec les mesurer avec les
compétences je dirais que sur lesquels
je m'appuie parce que c'est pas moi qui
ai les compétences particulières mais on
s'appuie sur les compétences de
scientifiques et puis d'un autre côté on
a aussi la responsabilité de pouvoir
faire travailler les entreprises et les
privés qui en ont besoin surtout en
cette période
la mairie attend donc les conclusions
des investigations et se dit prête à
agir tue des personnes qu'ils soient
malades
indéniablement ça c'est certain
maintenant si ici on devait se rendre
compte que ces installations devaient
développer ce genre de choses bien
évidemment je serai la première à
trouver les solutions dans la mesure de
mes capacités en tout cas en tant que
maire de son côté à tous n'a pas
souhaité répondre pour le moment à nos
sollicitations
dans l'actualité également jean castex
va faire un point sur la crise sanitaire
demain jeudi 10 décembre
bonsoir eléonore sinoquet on sera de la
rédaction de tv 78 le premier ministre
doit détailler les détails de
l'enlèvement du confinement c'est la
deuxième étape qui est prévue
normalement le 15 décembre mais au vu
des derniers
deux des derniers chiffres pardon cela
semble être plutôt compliqué plutôt
difficile ah oui compliqué le 15
décembre je vous rappelle devait marquer
la fin de l'attestation dérogatoire de
déplacement et puis également la
réouverture notamment des cinémas
théâtres salles de spectacles et musées
et tout cela uniquement si les
conditions sanitaires le permettait et
si la france passer la barre des 5000
cas en tout cas moins de 5000 cas par
jour cas positifs évidemment au co vide
puisque on en est loin encore de cet
objectif tourner on en est loin et hier
on a comptabilisé plus de 13 mille
nouveaux cas en france pour la région
ile de france c'était 1300 car rien que
pour cette unique secteur et en ce qui
concerne les ivy les contaminations par
jour tourner entre 150 et 300 nouveaux
cas
hier par exemple dans le département
nous étions à 171 nouvelles
contaminations
mais attention ce chiffre est plutôt
dans la moyenne basse des contaminations
car il faut préciser que le dimanche les
tests pcr ne sont pas ou peu réaliser ce
qui décale évidemment la
comptabilisation des cas d'après la
directrice départementale des yvelines
de la rs ile de france
nous sommes sur un plateau alors ce
plateau ça veut dire que pendant
quelques semaines
les chiffres ont baissé mais
qu'aujourd'hui les chiffres remontent
dans quelques endroits et les yvelines
en font partie mais on a compris cet
objectif de moins de 5000 nouveaux cas
de deux colis de 19 par jour ne sera
sûrement pas atteints d'ici mardi
quid du coup de l'allègement de ce
confinement mais c'est tout l'enjeu un
petit peu d annonce demain prévu par
jean castex qui fait affaire une
conférence de presse parce que cette
deuxième étape comme je vous le disais
juste avant ça devait marquer la
réouverture en fait les théâtres cinémas
musées
ça ne pourrait finalement pas être le
cas d'où l'inquiétude des professionnels
et on écoute justement la directrice du
théâtre l'espace coluche à plaisir je
suis comme toute la profession puisque
j'ai changé avec mes confrères on est
très très mal à c'est à dire que
comprends plus ce qui se passe en fait
le monde a été de très bon élève la
j'appréhende vraiment la fermeture des
quatre la non réouverture des théâtres
le 15 parce que
ce qui m'inquiète encore davantage ces
mois de janvier pour comprend pas on
comprend pas ces mesures qui qui savent
qu'ils sont total suppression pour les
uns et ouverture pour les autres je
pense qu'il faudrait un petit peu
d'équité il faut ré ouvrir l'état voilà
comme vous l'avez entendu un peu l'état
d'esprit des directeurs de théâtre on en
saura plus
évidemment demain la conférence de
presse de jean castex elle est prévue à
18 heures il reviendra probablement
aussi sur les nouvelles modalités d'un
peut-être couvre-feu on verra ça et puis
sur le déroulement des fêtes de fin
d'année merci et l'honneur pour toutes
ces précisions et on reviendra sur ce
qui est annoncé par le gouvernement
normalement dans nos éditions notamment
celle de vendredi sur tv 78 cette
mobilisation hier mardi à chevreuse une
partie du personnel de l'hôpital
gérontologique s'est rassemblée pendant
une heure devant l'établissement ces
professionnels du secteur médico social
dénonce leur exclusion du ségur de la
santé l'objectif pour le gouvernement
est est de revaloriser les personnels
hospitaliers des ehpad publics fortement
engagée dans la crise sanitaire est les
personnes mobilisées demandent à pouvoir
bénéficier de l'augmentation de 183
euros prévus par le ségur écouter cette
interview
[Musique]
environ une quarantaine de personnes
étaient présentes c'est donc hier donc
ça fait à peu près 25 % de l'effectif
total de l'établissement est à peu près
50% de l'effectif présent ir pour
l'égalité pour deux traitements pour
tout le personnel parce que dans
l'établissement il ya il ya différentes
il ya différents secteurs et donc à un
secteur sanitaire et un secteur médico
social et donc le médico-social donc n'a
pas touché les 183 euros prévus en fait
c'est pas une prime et en fait c'est un
complément un 17-2 de salaires donc en
fait au final dans l'établissement il y
aura une partie du personnel qui
touchera donc 183 euros en plus voilà et
c'est pas tout le monde n'est pas
concerné
[Musique]
nous on veut même motif même hôpital
même carrière en fait voilà et que le
décret le décret concerne tout le
personnel aussi le personnel
médico-social et que ce soit que qui
soit fait refait dans le dans les plus
brefs délais et que ce soit rétroactif
aussi original aussi patrons ont fait le
maire exactement le même travail que
quelqu'un dans le sanitaire mais au
final bas on n'est pas payé pareil on
ouvre une page politique dans ce journal
il a été élu député de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines le 27
septembre dernier philippe benassaya dû
s'adapter à cette nouvelle fonction nous
avons passé une matinée à l'assemblée
nationale avec le parlementaire ancien
maire de bois d'arcy un reportage de
nicolas landry il a effectué ses
premiers pas à l'assemblée nationale en
octobre dernier philippe benassaya
nouveau député de la 11e circonscription
des yvelines a pris le rythme de
l'activité parlementaire
une journée type c'est à la fois des
rencontres des rendez vous du travail
beaucoup beaucoup d'études travail de
commission sur toutes les thématiques
sur lesquelles je suis engagé donc
session des journées chargées en général
le mardi le mercredi et le jeudi
premier point au programme de sa matinée
une question orale une séance
particulière dans l'hémicycle avec une
question individuelle et directe du
parlementaire aux membres du
gouvernement le député yvelinois va
solliciter la ministre déléguée au
logement auprès de la ministre de la
transition écologique
madame la ministre à tyr votre attention
sur les difficultés que rencontre le
personnel pénitentiaire pour se loger
notamment dans le logement social
plus généralement les modalités
d'application de la loi sru pose de
grosses difficultés aux communes ce
sujet philippe benassaya le connaît à
travers la maison d'arrêt présente à
bois d'arcy ancien maire de cette
commune cette fonction d'élu local lui
permet d'agir aussi dans sa nouvelle
activité de législateurs une expérience
remarquer par ses collègues du groupe
l'est républicain
on a l'impression de philippe et d'un
serial est toujours été à l'assemblée
nationale tellement
il connaît ses sujets il maîtrise ses
dossiers et surtout c'est un homme de
terrain un racine est ancrée qui défend
des valeurs d'autorité mais aussi de
solidarité
on sent qu'il a une expérience d'élu
local comme j'ai pu l'être moi même et
le fait d'avoir été maire de bois d'arcy
lui donne évidemment une familiarité
avec beaucoup de sujets
après la réunion du groupe parlementaire
les lui yvelinois rejoint son bureau
membre de la commission des finances
engagé sur les sujets de sécurité
philippe benassaya a déjà travaillé sur
plusieurs textes de loi notamment à
travers des amendements
j'ai fait un amendement sur la police
sur les c s unissant de supervision
urbain
je prends un exemple dans ma
circonscription pour être toujours très
concret le mini de sony est dans une
petite communauté de communes ça
permettrait aux mines il des familles de
pouvoir se rattacher à la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin pour
bénéficier des csu le lien avec sa
circonscription le député l'est
républicain le conserve avec son rôle
d'élu départemental face à la loi du non
cumul des mandats il a été contrainte de
démissionner de sa fonction de maire
ça c'était un vrai crève coeur très
honnêtement j'ai mis un peu de temps à
passer du rôle de mère la députée donc
la transition elle n'a pas été évident
puis maintenant ça va puisque je garde
toujours bien sûr un oeil sur sur sur
bois d'arcy et sur l'ensemble des villes
de la circonscription pour conserver son
ancrage local philippe benassaya sera
candidat pour un nouveau mandat de
conseiller départemental pour le scrutin
de juin 2021
un reportage à retrouver également
demain dans un nouveau numéro du 7-8
politique tout comme une interview de
gérard larcher le président du sénat et
sénateur des yvelines reviendra sur
l'actualité politique autour de la
sécurité globale des conséquences du coc
vie de 19 sur l'économie l occasion
aussi de parler des présidentielles 2022
et de son soutien à valérie pécresse
dans la campagne des prochaines
élections régionales
interview complète a retrouvé ce jeudi à
21h sur tv 78 en attendant voici un
extrait les questions de nicolas landry
vous allez être président du comité de
soutien de valérie pécresse pendant
cette nouvelle quel rôle vous allez
jouer
et je l'avais déjà été la fois dernière
mon rôle c'est d'abord dans ma
responsabilité de deux sénateurs
d'indiquer que la proche que valérie
pécresse a du territoire francilien est
une approche qui correspond dans la
proximité ça n'est pas rien dans la
proximité avec plus de 12 millions
d'habitants
elle prend en compte cette formidable
région cette région capitale qui a une
responsabilité nationale majeure
si je prends un exemple en matière
environnementale et la bvk plus fait que
tous ceux qui se proclament et des
environnementalistes et donc dégagé avec
elle autour d'elle c'est le rôle d'un
président de comité de soutien j'allais
dire quelques éléments du projet qui
nous avait des projets partagés
nous ne devons pas oublier que l'île de
france est aussi un département comme la
seine saint denis avec d'immenses
difficultés et bien les réponses que
nous devons apporter
elles doivent s'adapter à chacun des
territoires mais elles doivent être une
marque commune celle de notre région
celle de ses responsabilités avec
notamment la dimension économique est
derrière la crise économique
la région sera un acteur majeur et si le
plan de relance réussie il ne réussira
qu'à une condition qu'ils soient des
concentrés au niveau de la région qu'au
niveau des départements et au niveau des
communes
un dernier mot pour conclure on sait que
vous suivez valérie pécresse depuis
plusieurs années maintenant est ce que
ces régionales pour elle ça représente
un tremplin peut-être pour les élections
présidentielles de la mine
c'est d'abord un tremplin pour la région
de france donc céder l'enjeu c'est
valérie pécresse encore
j'allais dire la tête de ligne de france
pour les six années qui viennent ça
m'apparaît tout à fait tout à fait
essentiel ensuite valérie pécresse est
une femme politique nationale c'est un
sujet il faudra que se dégage un
candidat dans les familles du centre de
la droite républicaine chez les
gaullistes un ou une candidate
c'est ce à quoi je travaille pour gagner
je vais dire le moment venu qu'un seul
candidat parce que je pense que nous
avons une responsabilité centre et la
droite c'est d'offrir une alternative à
emmanuel macron parce que si la seule
alternative c'est emmanuel macron marine
le pen ou emmanuel macron jean luc
mélenchon je pense que ça n'est pas
l'alternative c'est ce que je souhaite
après qu'il y ait un débat et bien en
très bonne macro et un candidat ou une
candidate que nous soutiendrons c'est
tout simplement une démocratie qui
fonctionne
avant de conclure vous dites que vous
travaillez dessus de quelle manière je
suis en train de voir tout au tout tout
tout les candidats ou les candidats
potentiels de réfléchir à ce qui
pourrait être une méthode de départage
mais laissez moi là un peu de ton on en
parlera au printemps merci gérard a fait
président et les républicains du sénat
et sénateur des yvelines
chaque année à la proche de noël
un quart des français l'accueille dans
son foyer le sapin incontournable des
fêtes
mais en cette année un peu particulière
les ventes sont elles au rendez vous
réponse dans ce reportage de célia gars
de son go aux essarts-le-roi et à
saint-cyr-l'ecole trouver le sapin idéal
pour mettre dans son salon les yvelinois
n'échappe pas à la tradition et ce n'est
pas la crise sanitaire qui va les
arrêter
en fait on vient chercher le sapin voilà
puisque ben avec la réouverture des
magasins on en profite
qui on va faire un petit peu le tour du
magasin pourra les décorations voilà
peut-être un petit peu de un peu de
joueurs cette période quoi il y a deux
semaines les commerçants ne savait pas
s'il pourrait vendre ses arbres de noël
c'est donc un soulagement pour eux on
est très content parce qu'on a on a faim
de sapin on va pouvoir satisfaire tous
nos clients qui sont vraiment en attente
c'est une symbolique de noël qui est
importante et les gens attendaient des
sapins comme juliette elle vient tous
les ans ici acheter son sapin
moi je reste vraiment un côté
traditionnel et l'épicéa qui est qui
sent bon le sapin le plus vendu reste le
nordmann il a la particularité de garder
ses épines vanessa génin et son époux
propose aux essarts-le-roi juste à côté
de la n 10 5 variétés différentes
on a pour tous les goûts voilà toutes
les tailles
on essaie de satisfaire un plus grand
nombre de clients après vous avez le
bleu voilà à mettre 50 1 m 75
cette année la montagne
on a beaucoup qui vont y aller tout un
ensemble qui fait qu'aujourd'hui le
sapin représente comme je vous ai dit la
montagne le plaisir le bonheur de se
dire que c'est des fêtes de fin d'année
qui vont pouvoir les faire en famille et
ils ont voulu vraiment se faire plaisir
sur un beau sapin de noël reste donc
plus qu elle est décorée en 2019 près de
2 foyers sur dix ont acheté un sapin de
noël naturel et puis à saint quentin en
yvelines depuis trois ans la commanderie
donnent rendez vous pour un noël décaler
cette année avec les mesures sanitaires
toujours en vigueur l'événement a lieu
en ligne c'est donc un hymne aux ailes
décalé qui vous est proposé avec au
programme lectures musicales marché de
noël virtuel ou encore ateliers en
visioconférence justin brasey la
commanderie revient avec son eee noël
décalé une programmation 100% ligne
cette année avec marché de noël virtuel
lectures musicales ou encore ateliers le
public ne manque que les artistes où
manquent les intervenants nous manque et
du coup on avait envie de ne pas rester
deux mois sans rien proposer à la
commanderie et de faire ce lien jusqu'à
la fin de l'année en espérant des jours
meilleurs mois de janvier les ateliers
sont accessibles à tous et variées au
programme fabrication de lanternes de
produits cosmétiques et réalisation de
recettes de cuisine et de cartes de noël
ou encore au yoga du rire des ateliers
pour les enfants des études pour les
adultes parce qu'on a envie eu envie de
concerner tous les publics
et donc voilà il suffit de s'inscrire de
choisir un ou des ateliers pour certains
ateliers le public vient chercher des
kits puisqu'on leur a préparé tout le
matériel pour pouvoir réaliser leur
fabrication en même temps que
l'intervenant en direct dit connexion au
maximum sont possibles par atelier une
fois inscrit un mémo est envoyé aux
participants indiquant leur ait un lien
pour se connecter
on se retrouve ensemble en visio comme
on a appris à le faire depuis quelques
mois d'être tous en visio voilà on a
tout organisé pour pour pouvoir les
accueillir
virtuellement la commanderie d'autres
ateliers auront lieu ce week end
fabrication de mangeoires à oiseaux ou
encore emballages cadeaux il est encore
possible de s'y inscrire programme et
réservations sur le site de la
commanderie
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]